en voilà une voilà la deuxième
contravention il était loin de
s'attendre à sare christian bourgault se
retraite haut-saônois de 69 ans a réussi
en l'espace de quelques mois
cinq pv de stationnement pour 100
tracteurs son tracteur justement
verbalisé à marseille à plus de 600
kilomètres de son village
donc c'est lui le responsable du délit
oui c'est lui le responsable du délit
oui exactement donc soit disant qu'il se
retrouve à marseille mais non ben il a
62 ans a valu et bien sûr que c'est un
vieux tracteur à 25 km heure difficile
d'imaginer christian partant en virée
dans la cité phocéenne avec son tracteur
alors que s'est il passé
et bien la plaque du tracteur a été
usurpée et un véhicule s'en est servi à
l'insu du retraité haut saônois il a
déposé plainte sauf contre deux les pv
ont été majorés âgées des majorations
sur les 400 et bien une majoration de 50
euros à chaque fois
aujourd'hui vous en aide à plus de 211 à
bah oui ça fait 250 euros les 4 nous
avons joué par téléphone la société qui
gère les pv de stationnement pour la
ville de marseille
contactée la ville de marseille qui a
décidé de procéder à l'annulation des
fps et 4 très fier dès lors que monsieur
bourgault avait bien un dépôt de plainte
pour usurpation de plaque
christian bourgault espère pouvoir enfin
refermer le dossier de cette histoire
totalement incroyable et d'ici là ils
pensent changer la plaque de son
tracteur pour ne plus être embêté